élaborer dans le cadre de la mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
mecs qui a choisi pour premier
évaluation au long cours de cette
législature de se consacrer aux
exonérations de cotisations sociales
elle s'est réunie la semaine dernière
pour approuver le rapport de Marc
Ferracci et Jérôme Guedj ici présent que
je remercie de nous présenter leur
travail ce matin avant que nous
n'entamions l'examen du PLFSS 2024 je
leur laisse donc la parole messieurs
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
tous Nous sommes très heureux avec mon
collègue Jérôme Guess de vous présenter
le résultat de nos réflexions je tiens
avant de commencer le propos et
d'évoquer le rapport à remercier très
chaleureusement les administrateurs de
la commission des affaires sociales qui
nous ont appuyé dans l'élaboration de ce
rapport et qui nous ont permis dans des
délais qu'on s'est donné qui étaient
assez contraints
d'aboutir à un travail je pense
satisfaisant alors ce rapport il part
d'un constat qui est documenté d'emblée
c'est que les exonérations de charges
sociales dans notre pays pèsent lourd
dans ce rapport nous n'avons pas
souhaité nous intéresser à l'intégralité
des dispositifs d'exonération de charges
sociales par manque de temps par manque
de données aussi c'est des sportifs sont
extrêmement nombreuses d'ailleurs été
documentées par récent rapport de Liga
CDF et je crois qu'ils sont au nombre de
147 ou 150 nous avons souhaité nous
focaliser sur les allégements généraux
de charges sociales qui représente une
masse qui n'a cessé de croître dans les
dernières années dans notre pays
puisqu'elle atteint aujourd'hui près de
3% du PIB l'équivalent de 80 milliards
d'euros quand on tient compte des effets
d'assiette la dispositifs d'assiettes
donc on a ici une exigence qui est
d'évaluée l'impact de cette dépense
l'impact de cette dépense au regard des
objectifs que lui fixe le législateur le
premier de ces objectifs depuis le début
des allègêtements généraux qui ont été
introduits au début des années 90 et
bien c'est la création d'emplois donc ça
a été notre première préoccupation que
d'interroger l'impact efficacité de ces
mesures d'allègement sur la création
d'emplois nous avons décliné trois
questions trois questions qui
intéressent aujourd'hui le débat public
nous sommes un petit peu inspirés des
problématiques qui avaient émergé dans
les derniers mois la première question
c'est de savoir si les allégements
généraux sont tous efficaces et en
particulier s'ils sont efficaces quelle
que soit le niveau de salaire
auquel il s'applique
et nous sommes parvenus à la conclusion
que si les exonérations sur les bas
salaires et en particulier sur les
salaires compris entre 1 et 6000 était
efficace en termes de maintien et de
création d'emploi et qu'il était
nécessaire de les conserver en revanche
les exonérations sur les plus hauts
salaires et en particulier sur les
salaires compris entre 2,5 et 3,5 on
parle ici d'exonération de cotisations
familles à hauteur de 1,8 points on
parle de bandeau familles pour cette
raison là ces exonérations tout portable
croire que elles n'ont que très peu
d'effets sur l'emploi que très peu
d'effets sur la compétitivité des
entreprises et la première des
recommandations que nous faisons avec
mon collègue Jérôme Guedj et bien c'est
de revenir sur ces exonérations pour
trouver aux milliard et demi d'euros que
représente le bandeau famille une
utilisation plus conforme à l'intérêt
général sur ce sujet je laisserai Jérôme
développé mais nous n'avons pas
forcément sur les mêmes idées sur les
conséquences politiques attirer d'une
éventuelle suppression du bandeau
famille pour ma part je considère que
ces sommes devraient être recyclées dans
des baisses de fiscalité ou de charges
pour les entreprises afin de ne pas
augmenter le prélèvement obligatoire sur
les entreprises mais des baisses de
fiscalité de charge qui soient plus
efficaces la deuxième question que nous
sommes posées et qui est dans le débat
public c'est la question de
l'opportunité ou non de conditionner les
exonérations à certaines actions des
entreprises ou des branches
professionnelles et en particulier parce
que la conditionnalité peut embrasser
beaucoup beaucoup de thèmes et de sujets
ça peut être une conditionnalité liée à
des actions environnementales la des
actions destinations de l'inclusion nous
nous sommes focalisés sur la question
d'une éventuelle conditionnalité à la
négociation salariale et en particulier
à la négociation salariale de branche
c'est une proposition qui est dans le
débat public et dans le contexte de la
future conférence sociale
nous n'avions pas anticipé mais qui
donne quand même une perspective à cette
à cette réflexion et bien nous avons
souhaité interroger l'opportunité et la
faisabilité de cette mesure
d'exonération alors là aussi je
laisserai peut-être compléter y aller
non le détail de ce que nous avons
exhumé mais le constat que nous faisons
c'est que à ce stade il ne nous semble
pas opportun d'envisager une telle
conditionnalité à la fois pour des
raisons principes l'idée selon laquelle
donner aux exonérations plus d'un
objectif alors qu'il y a déjà l'objectif
de maintien et de création de l'emploi
lui ajouter l'objectif de dynamisation
des salaires pourraient faire courir le
risque de n'atteindre aucun des
objectifs et ensuite il y a aussi des
questions de nature juridique
opérationnelles qui ont été soulevées
notamment par les administrations que
nous avons auditionnées et qui ne laisse
penser que le dispositif s'il devait
être mis en œuvre et en particulier au
niveau des branches générer une compl
serait probablement une usine à gaz
difficile à assumer donc même si la
réflexion peut et doit sans doute se
poursuit sur ce sujet à ce stade notre
recommandation est de ne pas de ne pas
aller vers ce type de mesure enfin la
troisième question que nous sommes
posées toujours dans le débat public et
dans le prolongement des échanges que
nous avons pu avoir à l'intérieur de
cette commission et dans l'hémicycle
pendant la réforme des retraites c'est
l'opportunité de savoir si pour
maintenir dans l'emploi les seniors pour
créer des emplois qui bénéficient au
seniors et seraient opportun d'abord des
exonérations de charge plus importantes
sur les seniors et donc fonder les
exonérations sur un critère d'âge là
aussi notre recommandation sur la base
des des travaux qui nous ont été
transmis de la littérature économique et
bien c'est de ne pas de ne pas aller
vers cette solution là il y a
certainement d'autres leviers pour
favoriser le maintien dans l'emploi des
seniors des exonérations de ce type
généreraient probablement de très forts
effets d'aubaine
le point de départ moitié sans doute
rassurant pour un certain nombre d'entre
nous qui nous approchons de du seuil
d'âge où on devient senior c'est que la
justification des exonérations et bien
c'est au fond de compenser un écart qui
peut exister entre la productivité et le
coût du travail c'est la raison pour
laquelle on cible les exonérations sur
les basses à l'air c'est-à-dire sur les
gens les moins productifs pour lesquels
évidemment le coût du travail peut être
plus élevé que la productivité la bonne
nouvelle entre guillemets que nous avons
exhumé c'est que il n'y a aucune preuve
selon laquelle les salariés seniors là
de 50 55 ans est une productivité plus
faible que celle des autres salariés et
donc il n'y a pas de justification
économique au fait de cibler les
exonérations sur ces catégories d'âge
voilà je vais pas être plus long je vais
laisser Jérôme compléter et préciser
parce que j'ai été évidemment très très
général et je pense que nos échanges
permettront d'aller au fond des choses
merci merci Marc en effet on va prendre
le temps d'échanger et de répondre à vos
à vos questions quelques quelques
éléments dans mon dans mon propos
introductif d'abord c'est un exercice un
peu inédit que de participer que à cet
exercice
d'évaluation des exonérations de
cotisation sociale j'assis sur le terme
le rapport ne mentionne à aucun moment
le terme de charge sociale et ils vont
veiller alors à l'oral certains le font
comme toi à l'instant moi je préfère
qu'on continue à parler d'exonération de
cotisations sociales inédit parce que
l'exercice pour l'instant est assez
nouveau pour la parfaite information
mais vous le savez dans le cadre de
la loi organique de Thomas Meunier à
partir de l'année prochaine il y a
l'obligation dans chaque l'axe dans la
loi de règlement de
du PLFSS de l'année précédente d'évaluer
un tiers de ces
exonérations de cotisations sociales
c'est une bonne nouveauté qui avait été
introduite par Thomas Meunier à la fin
de juste avant l'été une méthodologie
nous a été proposée avec un rapport de
Liga c'est de l'IGF et nous attendons
à partir de l'année prochaine un tiers
de ces exonérations qui devra être
désormais éclairé un peu plus et un peu
mieux que ça ne l'était dans l'annexe 5
du PLFSS les années précédentes je dis
ça parce que c'est la raison principale
qui a présidé à cette mission
il y a eu c'est le terme consacré un
effet d'emballement les exonérations de
de cotisations sociales notamment depuis
une dizaine d'années soit la du fait de
nouveaux dispositifs dispositif le cice
et sa transformation en exonération et
puis aussi la progression de la masse
salariale qui mécaniquement puisque les
exonérations sont assises sur un critère
rapport au SMIC on se sont traduit par
une explosion un seul chiffre le
doublement des exonérations générales on
est passé 37 milliards en 2013 à 77
milliards cette année il y a quasiment
aucune dépense publique dans le budget
qui est connaît un doublement sur cette
période et en face on a très peu
d'évaluations de l'efficacité de ces
exonérations avec une sorte de confiance
et c'est donc l'objectif que nous nous
étions assignés de mettre pardonnez-moi
l'expression un peu le pied dans la
porte pour que le Parlement participe à
ces évaluations régulièrement en lien
avec le travail que l'exécutif doit nous
proposer je le dis tout de suite c'est
la raison pour laquelle ce rapport
on souhaite d'une manière ou d'une autre
le prolonger en affinant en affinant nos
travaux
je vais je vais droit au but
Marc l'a rappelé
nous avons souhaité cibler en première
intention
les exonérations sur les plus hauts
salaires et donc ce fameux ce fameux ce
fameux bandeau bandeau famille pour
lequel il y avait se dégage-t-il il se
dégager pardon à une forme de de
consensus des économistes qu'on a voulu
vérifier à travers des auditions qui ont
eu lieu dans cette dans cette salle sur
l'effet sur l'emploi et sur la
compétitivité
au dessus donc on parle de salaire entre
4200 et 6000 euros brut
pour lesquels il y avait une
interrogation sur l'efficacité en termes
d'emploi et en termes de de
compétitivité et donc nous confirmons ça
a été rappelé que elle ne semble pas
avérée on parle d'un milliard et demi
donc c'était aussi un des enjeux
estimé l'impact de cette exonération
d'un milliard et demi d'exonération sur
sur ces niveaux et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous en proposons la
suppression
alors chacun dans son
avant-propos
explique ce qu'il voudrait en faire
c'est l'échange qu'on va avoir ici pour
la petite histoire cette mission elle
est née du constat dans cette salle au
moment du PLFSS l'année dernière
d'amendement identique de marque
ferrachi et de moi pour proposer déjà la
suppression du bandeau famille même si à
l'époque dans nos exposés des motifs
nous n'avions pas la même la même la
même utilisation
le rapport je parle de mes le pied dans
la porte quand même
questionne même si la porte pas de
réponse enfin tous les cas fée écho des
interrogations que plusieurs économistes
et acteurs ont mentionné devant nous qui
est que entre 1,6 et 2,5
la question peut se poser nous
n'apportons pas de manière aussi de
réponse aussi tranchée que s'agissant
au-dessus de 2,5 sur le bandeau le
bandeau famille mais le bandeau maladie
en gros qui est le gros de l'exonération
entre 1,6 et 2,5 donc là on est autour
de 20 à 25 milliards
sur lequel nous pensons qu'il faudrait
prolonger les travaux de de d'évaluation
et d'appréciation en tous les cas au
regard des objectifs à signer
un dernier point qui est une incidence
on a souhaité aussi mentionner des
éléments bien sûr en rappelant que ces
exonérations sont compensées donc elles
n'ont pas d'impact sur le budget de la
Sécurité sociale l'État décide
d'exonération dans le cas de sa
politique de l'emploi et compense soit
par des financements directs soit le
plus souvent en pluguant enfin en
affectant une partie des recettes
fiscales de la TVA ou autre au
financement de la de la sécurité sociale
j'attire collectivement notre attention
parce vous souhaitez le mentionner qu'il
reste quand même une exonération
générale qui n'est pas compensée qui a
été décidé en 2019 qui est la
désocialisation des heures
supplémentaires quand elle a été
réintroduite et c'est 2 milliards et
demi c'est à dire que la sécurité
sociale
Patty un manque de ressources de 2
milliards et demi qui a été décidé par
l'État et au moment puisque aujourd'hui
le PLFSS nous est présenté avoir en tête
que c'est presque un tiers du déficit de
la Sécurité sociale qui nous est
présenté dans le PLFSS aujourd'hui c'est
parce que l'État ne compense pas une
exonération qu'il a lui-même décider
voilà je pense que ça vaut le coup de se
de se rappeler de se rappeler cette
donnée alors je vais aller vite sur
l'autre volet qui a été qui a été
mentionné qu'à la question de la
conditionnalité puisque le débat a eu
lieu donc on rappelle dans le rapport
les positions des organisations
syndicales sur
cet objectif de conditionnalité d'abord
on a voulu faire un peu d'archéologie
en rappelant ce qu'on connaissait pas
forcément on peut se le dire tout à fait
honnêtement qu'il existe déjà un
principe de conditionnalité qui a été
introduit par la loi du 3 décembre 2008
sur l'obligation de négociation annuelle
sur les salaires
et ce qui a été intéressant de constater
vous avez les chiffres dans le rapport
c'est qu'il y a cette obligation mais
qui a eu très peu de sanctions les
chiffres ont été rappelés dans le dans
le rapport on est en été entre 2009 et
2015 entre 75 et 325 entreprises qui ont
été sanctionnées pour des montants
dérisoires un million à 10 millions
d'euros bref au total sur toute la
période à peine 25 millions d'euros de
sanctions pour des entreprises qui n'ont
pas respecté l'obligation de négociation
de négociation annuelle et donc comme le
rappeler Marc la question de la
faisabilité a été posée et tout ce
cristallise dans à ce stade à ce stade
il est pas apparu praticable de
d'introduire cette logique de
conditionnalité dans le point qu'on a
retenu qui est celui de des branches
pour lesquelles les minimas
conventionnels sont inférieurs sont
inférieurs sur inférieur au SMIC
notamment pour celles des entreprises
vertueuses mais qui seraient dans une
branche qui le serait qui le serait
moins je vous considère là aussi que
pour autant le débat n'est pas clos
d'abord parce que d'autres éléments de
conditionnalités au hormis autre que
celui-ci peut être mis peuvent être mis
sur la table sur la qualité de l'emploi
sur l'égalité famom sur
la RSE sur les la transition la
transition écologique et que
au-delà de l'aspect de la faisabilité
des données qui peuvent être recueillies
alors bien sûr c'est une contrainte pour
les entreprises mais au moment où on met
des conditionnalités à plein d'endroits
inenvisageable que ça puisse être le cas
des entreprises mais je veux pas qu'on
anticipe sur le débat qu'on doit et
qu'on peut et qu'on peut avoir voilà je
veux pas être moi non plus plus long sur
la mesure d'exonération liée à l'âge là
pour le coup on a on a un consensus qui
s'est clairement clairement dégagé en
termes à la fois de faisabilité et de et
d'opportunités voilà mais il y a
tellement d'autres sujets que je vous
propose qu'on allait changer maintenant
en fonction des interrogations des uns
des autres merci merci messieurs les
rapporteurs nous allons donc
entendre les orateurs de groupe en
commençant par Madame janvier pour le
groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente et un grand
merci messieurs les rapporteurs pour ce
rapport très précis très clair et qui
permet aussi de retracer et bien
l'histoire de cette exonération de
cotisation sociale et des débats qui qui
sont liés avec évidemment vous vous
replacez le la question de ces
cotisations qui sont des revenus
différés et je partage ce point de vue
qui sont qui permettent de financer des
risques eux-mêmes couvert par la
Sécurité sociale avec ce débat dans les
années 90 sur les le coût du travail et
mais aussi celui de la compétitivité des
entreprises et donc rappeler finalement
l'objectif principal de ces exonérations
qui étaient favorisées l'emploi et c'est
quelque chose que je crois nous
entendons tous Lorsque nous discutons
avec des chefs d'entreprise notamment
les PME qui nous disent parfois et bien
renoncer à recruter du fait de ce que du
travail c'est intéressant de confronter
et bien cette réalité que nous entendons
aux études plus théoriques et bien vous
vous constatez qu'effectivement au-delà
entre 2,5 et 3,5 les effets ne sont pas
avérés et donc vous arrivez à ce
consensus d'une
inefficacité finalement de cette
politique publique sur et bien les plus
haut salaires et donc là proposition que
vous faites de et bien supprimer cette
ce bandeau famille cette exonération
avec malheureusement je dirais un
désaccord sur la façon dont vous
pourriez dont nous pourrions utiliser
cette économie réalisée de 1,5 milliards
et donc ma première question est de
savoir si il ne serait pas possible que
nous arrivions au sein de cette
commission à nous mettre d'accord sur et
bien cette suppression de de ce bandeau
famille en laissant peut-être la
de côté la question de son utilisation
où en arrivant pourquoi pas à une
solution consensuelle je vous remercie
merci
pour le rassemblement national merci
madame la Présidente merci messieurs les
rapporteurs pour être deuxième
présentation de votre rapport qui est
très intéressant je dois le dire il
était urgent d'évaluer les conséquences
objectifs et l'impact des exonations
sociales massives et des exemples
d'assiettes au regard des 80 milliards
qu'elle représente cela est évident de
même qu'il était il est évident qu'il
était indécent de ne pas l'avoir fait
mieux et plutôt découvrir
qu'éventuellement dans un a priori
réaliste 5 à 10% de ce montant serait
inefficient ce sont 4 à 8 milliards qui
correspondraient à tout autant de
recettes en Suisse ou de compensation
d'État en moins selon le point de vue
c'est d'ailleurs aussi le montant
d'économie espéré dans les mesures
présentées par le ministre des comptes
publics ces jours-ci
les allégements généraux vont retenir
mon attention c'est un des trois piliers
de votre étude il représente les trois
quarts des niches sociales rapportées
Europe et 96% rapportées au secteur
privé il pauvre profiterait en
particulier aux petites entreprises que
nous soutenons bien évidemment et porte
avant tout sur les bas salaires de A à
un sismique
selon vous ce ne serait pas un mécanisme
de trappe à bas salaire et c'est là que
nous ne partageons pas votre avis
car les secteurs concernés sont
évidemment des secteurs en tension
aujourd'hui l'hôtellerie la restauration
les services administratifs et de
soutien or ils ont la particularité
d'être non délocalisables pour maintenir
la compétitivité pour certains salariés
garder leur prime d'activité c'est ce
que nous avons découvert dans votre
dossier il ne fait donc il ne faut donc
pas augmenter les salaires et les
maintenir les plus proches possibles des
salaires délocalisés c'est donc une main
d'oeuvre étrangère seule capable
d'accepter des salaires non attractifs
en France qui acceptent ces emplois
c'est donc une délocalisation à domicile
à l'inverse pour les pays d'origine de
ces travailleurs c'est une
externalisation de leur économie ainsi
25% du Pipe des Comores repose
aujourd'hui sur les diaspora alors pour
cette raison majeure et d'autres plus
vénielles comme la suppression du
bandeau famille nous pensons qu'il y a
d'autres façons de soutenir les PME et
nous ne partageons donc pas de vos
conclusions et vos propositions merci
messieurs
merci Monsieur Ruffin pour la France
insoumise merci
l'État est devenu un puissant dealer de
subvention un narcotique auquel les
entreprises françaises aiment se shooter
qui a écrit ça c'est pas moi c'est pas
un leader de la CGT c'est pas attaque
c'est un ancien cadre du Medef
responsable des affaires sociales David
vera et qui poursuit sa métaphore les
entreprises françaises sont malades de
cette addiction à la subvention déguisée
celle-ci agit comme de la cocaïne elle
donne l'illusion temporaire de la
puissance et de la force mais elle ruine
la santé à petit feu donc je vous
remercie pour votre apport qui vient
mettre un peu d'ordre ce torrent
subvention qui ont triplé en disant
passant de 26 milliards d'euros
d'exonération sociale de 26 milliards
d'euros à 77 milliards d'euros cette
année si on ajoute les autres aides
chrétiens pour recherche et ainsi de
suite on arrive sans doute aux alentours
de 160 milliards d'euros tout ça sans
aucune condition ni sociale ni fiscale
ni environnement ale et donc
grand merci de mettre la lumière
là-dessus et notamment de revoir de dire
que voilà au-delà de Smic ça n'a plus
d'efficacité en terme d'emploi ça n'a
plus d'efficacité économique
merci Monsieur Ferracci d'entamer cette
remise en cause merci Jérôme d'aller
plus loin parce que je pense que on va
prendre ça ce qui est ce qui est votre
apport c'est un pied dans la porte ou un
orteil dans la porte mais il est évident
que derrière il va y avoir des questions
à se poser sur ce cet énorme paquet de
160 milliards d'euros d'aide aux
entreprises et donc c'est ainsi qu'on le
prend pourquoi il faut le faire il faut
le faire parce que l'État a besoin de
moyens les besoins de moyens pour
repartir sur l'hôpital l'État a besoin
de moyens pour rebâtir son école l'État
a besoin de moyens pour affronter le
choc climatique et il y a deux moyens de
les avoir un une fiscalité juste qui
fait que les milliardaires soient pas
aujourd'hui sous taxés par rapport aux
Français moyen et deuxièmement aller
chercher dans cette masse de subventions
qui aujourd'hui donnée comme un dealer
comme le dit cet ancien cadre d'une
médaille merci Monsieur Viry pour le
groupe les républicains
oui merci madame la Présidente par votre
travail chers collègues vous avez prouvé
s'il en était besoin l'utilité de la
Mecque
travail
conséquent d'évaluation de dépenses
d'État ou de dépenses d'organismes
sociaux pour tenter d'améliorer le sort
de chacun le pays en général mais aussi
la situation individuelle des personnes
je voudrais saluer la qualité de votre
travail j'ai vu les auditions que vous
aviez conduite de façon très éclectique
avec la volonté effectivement de poser
un diagnostic mais aussi une vision et
moi je sais ce que je retiens de votre
travail et d'ailleurs une suite doit
être donnée on verra laquelle et
probablement que nous aurons des
divergences mais lorsqu'on met le pied
dans la porte comme l'a dit notre
collègue Ruffin on peut pas
effectivement rester au milieu du guet
sur un sujet comme celui-ci
parce qu'en fait vous nous proposez une
vision à terme sur la question de
l'allongement des charges sociales et
tous les gouvernements de droite de
gauche est d'ailleurs on cherchait à
renforcer la compétitivité de notre
économie et de nos entreprises en
baissant le coût du travail qui
effectivement nous rend en difficulté
par rapport à d'autres pays donc c'est
un véritable sujet et la réponse a été
effectivement l'allongement des charges
et vous nous proposez aujourd'hui des
recommandations avec me semble-t-il à
consensus sur les dés que en dessous de
10,5 SMIC ça va il y a une efficacité
d'utilité au dessus tous discute
n'oublions jamais mes chers collègues
que les charges sociales les cotisations
sociales c'est le revenu de remplacement
et c'est la protection sociale si on
modifie ça ça veut dire il faut financer
la protection sociale autrement par de
la fiscalité première question faut-il
la conditionnalité faut-il une
conditionnalité moi j'avoue que ce sujet
il m'intéresse effectivement décider
qu'il faut pu baisser les charges
sociales ce serait à mon avis suicidaire
par rapport à cet enjeu de compétitivité
ne faut-il pas pour autant de demander
une contrepartie la question mérite
d'être posée en tout cas on ne pourra
pas exclure de nos travaux la nécessité
de renforcer le salaire net dans notre
pays parce que en creux c'est ce que
sous tantôt votre rapport merci Monsieur
Cyril isaccibil pour le groupe démocrate
merci Madame présidente
donc d'abord je voulais remercier
directivement tout l'intérêt du rôle de
la Mecque effectivement par rapport à ça
je trouve que les dangers de la coprésil
avec Jérôme et je trouve c'est un
formidable travail que vous avez fait
qui rend hommage à la Mecque le je
trouve que le travail vous avez fait
très intéressant par rapport à
l'historique je trouve effectivement
grosso modo on vote tous les ans des
textes sans vraiment comprendre le
pourquoi et donc cet éclairage que vous
avez fait très intéressant même au
niveau sémantique là elle Timone dans
nos débats on peut parler d'allègement
ou d'exonération de cotisations
ou de cotisations ou de charges sociales
tout ça c'est assez intéressant au
niveau politique de voir comment est
immense ces cotisations sociales sont
perçues
moi ce que je remarque c'est
effectivement c'est qu'on arrive un
petit peu à un point de bascule on fait
actuellement l'analyse de ces
exonérations
en 2023 par rapport à l'équipement ce
qui a pu être faite il y a 10-15 ans il
y a un point de bascule dans le sens où
on se rend compte et c'est ça qui est
intéressant on se rend compte que il y a
15 ans le problème et le dimanche
c'était l'emploi c'était le chômage et
que grosso modo on est dans un autre
monde on était il y a 15 ans dans un
chômage de masse grâce à une politique
qu'il faut quand même réaffirmer on
n'est plus dans ce chômage de masse et
effectivement des plutôt dans un
problème de tension des tensions de
certains secteurs et je trouve cette
historique que vous faites est
intéressant parce que on voit sa mère en
évidence cette espèce de bascule on est
passé effectivement d'un monde à un
autre je trouve le travail est
intéressant dans le sens qui ment et
c'est bien au sein de cette commission
au sein de la messe on peut arriver à
des consensus et on peut que vous
féliciter par rapport à ce consensus
notamment par rapport à la remise en
cause du bandeau famille entre deux et
deux cinq et trois cinq SMIG donc pour
celles qui m'ont bien évidemment il fera
caddie qui est des suites mais je trouve
c'est intéressant cette analyse cet
historique par rapport effectivement à
différentes périodes et différentes
problématiques qu'on traverse notre pays
merci beaucoup monsieur Delaporte pour
le groupe socialiste merci madame la
Présidente je trouve qu'il est précieux
d'avoir des moments comme celui-ci en
commission des affaires sociales parce
que pour une fois on peut dépasser les
préjugés les idées reçues et mettre à
plat finalement une situation et se dire
que à partir de ce constat sans appel
que vous faites dans votre rapport il y
a des éléments pour légiférer c'est
finalement tout l'inverse de ce qu'on
est en train de faire aujourd'hui en
séance où on légifère sans constat donc
voilà merci Monsieur Guedj merci
Monsieur Ferracci d'avoir su travailler
en bonne intelligence pour mettre en
avant un certain nombre d'éléments
je j'aurais deux questions ou de pistes
de réflexion mais il y a quand même un
long débat depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années mais monsieur Guedj était ici
même quand on réfléchissait notamment il
faut le dire au cice et à la question de
la conditionnalité des aides
vous montrer donc que ça pourrait enfin
vous l'avez esquissé dans votre
discussion mais ce que vous pourriez
aller un peu plus loin là-dessus sur
peut-être ce qui reste encore étranger
mais comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
conditionnaliser ses aides pour les
rendre plus efficaces quelles sont les
pistes qui pourraient nous amener
derrière à travailler à des amendements
éventuellement transpartisans on peut
l'espérer pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas d'une dépense d'argent public
superflu enfin une deuxième question il
y a 2,5 millions d'exonérations 2,5
milliards pardon de de charges liées à
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
qui ne sont pas compensées et qui grève
le budget de la Sécurité sociale à
l'heure où finalement on cherche des
économies de bout de chandelle sur
différents sujets est-ce que vous pensez
pas qu'il y a là un enjeu public à ce
que l'État assure la compensation de
l'exonération des des heures
supplémentaires pour rééquilibrer leur
déficit artificiellement creusé voilà
merci Monsieur Gernigon pour le groupe
horizon
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
collec donc je tiens tout d'abord à
remercier donc les deux rapporteurs pour
le travail donc vous avez accompli dans
le cadre de ce rapport sur le contrôle
de l'efficacité des exonérations donc de
cotisations sociales face à l'impératif
d'une allocation transparente et
démocratique des fonds publics plus que
jamais dans notre contexte qui nécessite
une réduction de la dépense publique
pour permettre de nouvelles avancées
votre rapport se penche sur les
implications des allégements de charges
sociales accordées aux entreprises qui
enregistrent vous le montrez une
croissance substantielle pour culminer
après de 80 milliards
en particulier pour les tranches
salariales élevées peuvent avoir un
effet trop limité sur l'emploi
comme vous je pense qu'il est de bon
sens et primordial de systématiser
l'évaluation d'impact des dépenses
publiques et comme vous l'avez souligné
de remettre en cause celles dans
l'efficacité n'est pas avérée comme ici
La Maxe le permet
votre rapport soulève également la
question de l'adaptation des
exonérations pour favoriser davantage
l'emploi des seniors offrant ainsi une
base solide pour un dialogue constructif
sur cette question cruciale je suis en
accord avec votre perspective selon
laquelle une exonération supplémentaire
pourrait ne pas surmonter efficacement
les défis qui limitent le taux d'emploi
des seigneurs il me semble que
simplifier les contrats destinés au
Seigneur serait une meilleure solution
pour une intégration sur le marché du
travail
favoriser l'adoption de ces contrats
pour les entreprises me semble plus
judicieux que de toujours proposer des
agitations financières qui ont prouvé à
plusieurs reprises leur échec
lorsqu'elles sont censées seules
un point de votre rapport a également
retenu mon attention celui des
exonérations pour les jeunes entreprises
innovantes les propositions récentes du
député Paul midi concernant
l'élargissement de s'exonération ce sont
accompagnés de projections et selon
celle-ci un investissement d'un peu plus
d'un milliard d'euros pourrait entraîner
la création de 100 000 emplois c'est une
proposition ambitieuse et je
souhaiterais savoir si vous avez étudié
cette piste et si elle correspond à
votre vision d'accentuer le ciblage des
exonérations en vue d'atteindre le plein
emploi
pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente et je tiens
également
à saluer le travail donc des deux
rapporteurs un rapport Charpin de 92
rapport malinvaux de 2001 rapport
gallois de 2012 depuis 30 ans les
rapports s'enchaînent promettant une
baisse du chômage contre une baisse des
cotisations sociales des entreprises
depuis 30 ans les gouvernements
successifs font la part belle locatrice
du Medef et à la grande fable de la
théorie du ruissellement aujourd'hui
nous disposons enfin d'un rapport
qu'elle mérite de remettre en question
l'efficacité de ces milliards de cadeaux
aux entreprises car comme le constat
ajuste titre notre collègue Jérôme Guedj
ces exonérations constituent d'abord une
perte de recettes pour la puissance
publique et pour notre système de santé
rien qu'entre 2019 et 2022 en pleine
crise sanitaire le montant cumulé des
exonérations de cotisations à représenté
278 milliards d'euros
278 milliards d'euros alors que 5
milliards d'euros seraient nécessaires
pour endiguer la crise de l'hôpital
public que 9 billards financeraient la
prise en charge la dépendance et que
pour 13 milliards d'euros nous pouvions
nous passer donc de la réforme des
retraites ces exonérations en masse qui
dans le cas du bandeau famille s'avère
d'ailleurs particulièrement inefficace
sur l'emploi pour les salaires entre 2,5
et 3,5 fois le SMIC ce rapport a
également le mérite d'étudier la
pertinence du conditionnement des
exonérations sociales à des objectifs
sociaux car avec 80 milliards d'euros
d'exonération et 144 milliards publics
annuels nous considérons que nous avons
assez signé de chaque en blanc à des
entreprises et qu'il est temps qu'elles
prennent leur part de responsabilité
pour répondre à l'urgence sociale et
climatique nous attendons donc beaucoup
de la Commission et de la Mecque pour
contribuer à une meilleure information
des députés sur le conditionnement des
exonérations à des impératifs sociaux et
écologiques dans un contexte où le culte
de la croissance passe toujours plus
devant l'objectif d'atteindre la pleine
santé pour tout et tous merci Monsieur
d'arriville pour le groupe GDR
si madame la Présidente
Ferracci et Jérôme Guedj pour pour ce
travail au sein de la Mecque
bon moi j'aurais aimé qu'on parle aussi
un peu des vertus de la cotisation en
fait
parce qu'en réalité
toutes ces exonérations
elle repose sur une sorte d'idée reçue
sur lequel les cotisations seraient par
nature nocives
et notamment aussi pour l'emploi
alors moi je pense que ces exonérations
massives
porte atteinte à la cotisation au
principe de cotisations et je crois
qu'il faut réhabiliter ce principe de
cotisation et ces exonérations massives
au moment où elle montait en charge
elles ont accompagnées une montée en
puissance de la crise du système de
santé donc je crois que ça devrait nous
interroger alors dans le constat que
vous faites et l'interrogation que vous
portez sur les effets de ces
exonérations j'en partage une partie je
trouve que c'est déjà bien de mettre en
cause les exonérations liées au
salaire entre guillemets au-dessus de
2,5 pas tous des hauts salaires
d'ailleurs
cela dit
je crois qu'il y a dans ces politiques
qui ont été menées une confusion c'est à
dire que ça n'est pas la sécurité
sociale de financer les politiques de
l'emploi
c'est à la puissance publique de
financer donc à l'état de financer les
politiques de l'emploi
or quand on décide de produire des
exonérations de cotisation en réalité on
fait financer par l'impôt donc pour
partie par les salariés ce qui
auparavant relevait la cotisation
patronale donc il y a un transfert qui
s'opère
dans
dans le partage des richesses
et donc je crois que ça ça pose un
problème et qu'il faudrait interroger
cette réalité là
if le gros pilote
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteur merci pour votre travail la
question de la légitimité de
l'efficacité des exonérations de charge
au cotisation sociale se pose
aujourd'hui avec d'autant plus de force
que nous sommes en recherche constante
de ressources supplémentaires pour
financer notre système de protection
sociale il doit évoluer avec le
vieillissement de la population en
française la nécessaire adaptation de
l'offre de soins et d'accompagnement qui
en découlent l'explosion des maladies
chroniques l'adaptation de l'offre
médico-sociale pour accompagner nos
aînés ou tout simplement l'évolution du
niveau d'exigence des usagers sur ce que
doit être une prise en charge de qualité
en 2023 dans notre pays les règles
d'hier ne sont en effet pas forcément
adaptés à une société dans les besoins
ont évoluer et les légitimes de les
interroger mais je souhaite néanmoins
formuler plusieurs remarques sur
l'hypothèse de la baisse des
exonérations de cotisations présentes
dans ce rapport où elles sont évaluées
comme peu ou pas efficace vous reprenez
précisément les différentes mesures qui
ont été appliquées au fil des décennies
pour arriver à la situation actuelle
avec 80 milliards d'exonération
d'abord la notion de stabilité fiscale
et sociale les entreprises ont besoin
d'une chose essentielle qui n'est pas
toujours le niveau mais la tendance du
coût du travail comme pour les autres
coulis à leur activité je pense
d'ailleurs que c'est d'autant plus vrai
que l'entreprise est petite c'est la
question de la visibilité pour le chef
d'entreprise le risque de déplacement de
la rémunération la baisse des
exonérations est une hausse du coût du
travail qui peut avoir comme effet
collatéral à ses simples de déplacer les
rémunérations pour ceux qui dépassent
les seuils que vous souhaitez fixer ou
revisiter vers des outils défiscalisés
ou des socialiser qui sentent elles à la
disposition d'entreprise pour éviter de
faire évoluer sa masse salariale ce qui
représenterait alors une perte sèche
pour le financement de la sécurité
sociale rien plutôt que moins le Tasman
des salaires autre risque d'autant plus
lorsque vous évoquez l'affirmation d'un
seuil à 1 sismique et non plus au-delà
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui avec même
un renforcement des exonérations autour
de ce seuil
les chefs d'entreprises ne méconnent pas
ses seuils ou ses exonérations s'ils ne
recrute pas bien sûr pour une personne
en fonction de cela à l'échelle d'une
entreprise sur la durée la conséquence
des effets de seuil est à envisagé merci
je viens de me faire l'avocat du diable
ces remarques ne sont pas des
oppositions à vos propositions mais des
réflexions je vous remercie merci
beaucoup je vais dans un premier temps
passer la parole à Monsieur les
rapporteurs pour des premières réponses
aux questions qui ont été soulevées et
ensuite on poursuivra les questions des
députés
merci merci beaucoup pour pour toutes
vos interventions on va essayer de faire
un peu synthèse des différents points
qui ont été soulevés et je vais
peut-être repartir de l'intervention de
de Monsieur panifou et aussi en écho à
celle de Madame Melun jusqu'au fond
qu'est-ce que ça pose c'est ces
problématiques c'est la question des
trappes à basse à l'air et de la
possibilité que les exonérations
ralentissent voire bloc les
augmentations de salaire alors c'est un
sujet sur lequel on s'est penché dans le
cadre du rapport on a posé la question
et on a interrogé un certain nombre de
d'études économiques qui ont cherché à
évaluer l'existence ou non de trappes à
bas salaire sur ce sujet je pense qu'il
faut être précis par trappe à bas
salaire on entend l'idée que au-delà de
certaines de certains niveaux de salaire
et bien il n'y a plus aucune incitation
pour l'employeur et pour le salarié à
augmenter le salaire tout simplement
parce que la ponction sur le salaire
brut est trop importante ou parce que la
perte de certains éléments de
rémunération et on pense en particulier
à la prime d'activité en moins
intéressante l'augmentation salariale
sur ce sujet que disent les études les
études disent que à proximité des seuils
je reprends le la réflexion qui vient
d'être faite à proximité des seuils on
ne constate pas de points de masse
c'est-à-dire d'un grand nombre de
salaires qui soient bloqué un peu en de
sa des seuil c'est en cela qui nous est
possible de dire que les études en
l'état actuel des connaissances que nous
avons ne mettent pas en évidence de
trappe à bas salaire est-ce que ça
signifie que notamment entre 1 et 1
sismique il n'y a pas de ralentissement
ou de frein à l'augmentation salariale
qui soit engendré par l'existence des
exonérations
c'est une question à laquelle nous que
nous laissons ouverte que nous laissons
ouverte mais ça n'est pas stricto sensu
une trappe à bas salaire pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a possibilité d'un frein aux
augmentations de salaire notamment entre
1 et 1 sismique parce que vous avez la
coexistence de deux points de sortie
vous avez le point de sortie des
exonérations générales à 1,6 SMIC qui
ensuite débouches sur ce qu'on appelle
le bandeau maladie
entre 1,6 et 2,5 et vous avez aussi le
point de sortie de la prime d'activité
donc il est possible que en cas de la
négociation salariale qui a lieu entre
un employeur et son salarié à proximité
de 1,6 l'employeur soit fondé à dire je
n'ai pas d'intérêt à aller beaucoup plus
loin que 1,6 parce que les exonérations
vont chuter du fait cet effet de seuil
et qu'en même temps le salarié soit
fondé à dire de toute façon
l'augmentation au-delà de 1,5 me fait
perdre une partie de ma prime d'activité
et donc au fond trouvant un arrangement
différent c'est une possibilité c'est
une possibilité que nous avons
explicitement mentionné dans le rapport
sur laquelle nous ne disposons pas des
données et en particulier des données
croisées entre les entreprises et les
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité
pour répondre à l'existence de telle
mécanismes et donc nous recommandons de
poursuivre le travail et la réflexion
sur l'existence de trappe à bas salaire
et en particulier entre 1 et 1 sismique
l'autre point sur lequel je voudrais je
voudrais simplement revenir
c'est au fond cette
[Musique]
interprétation qu'on donne aux résultats
des études économiques qui disent qu'il
y a pas beaucoup d'effets sur l'emploi
des exonérations sur les hauts salaires
pourquoi au fond quel est le mécanisme
fondamentalement
les effets sur l'emploi il dépendent de
la manière dont les entreprises
répercutent les exonérations ou pas sur
les salaires des employés
sur les bas niveau de salaire les
employeurs répercutent assez peu les
exonérations sur les salaires ça veut
dire que elle garde des possibilités
d'embaucher ou d'investir et c'est pour
ça que les effets sur l'emploi et
l'activité sont forts s'agissant des
exonérations sur les basses à l'air
lorsque vous êtes entre 2,5 et 3,5 les
salariés ont un pouvoir de négociation
plus important parce qu'ils sont plus
qualifiés parce que ils sont face à un
marché du travail qui est plus tendu
parce que le taux de chômage à ces
niveaux de qualification est très faible
et il se passe que ils vont capter à
travers des renégociations salariales
qui ont lieu intervalles réguliers tous
les ans ils vont capter le bénéfice des
exonérations sous forme d'augmentation
de salaire brut et concrètement ces
exonérations bénéficient moins
l'entreprise qu'aux salariés les plus
qualifiées alors on pourra voir une
autre réflexion qui est de savoir si il
est pertinent de subventionner le
salaire des salariés les plus qualifiés
avec des exonérations et nous semble que
l'objectif qui est poursuivi par les
exonérations c'est me soutenir de
maintenir l'emploi et pas forcément de
soutenir les salaires les plus élevés
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a c'est
on a ces résultats que on souhaite
défendre voilà je vais pas forcément
être plus long si peut-être quand même
en réaction à la première remarque qui a
été faite par
Caroline janvier sur sur l'opportunité
pour pour notre commission se prononcer
bon on va pas je pense se cacher d'un
autre petit doigt avec Jérôme on a comme
il l'a dit tout à l'heure déposer des
amendements l'année dernière qui avec
des arguments différents et
l'utilisation différente de ces sommes
préconisées la suppression du bandeau
famille je pense que on va faire de même
probablement pas des amendements
similaires parce qu'on a toujours des
divergences sur l'utilisation à faire de
ce bandeau de famille mais tout ça pour
dire qu'on aura à discuter dans notre
commission de de cette question là et on
verra si un consensus se dégage sur sur
la suppression je vais je vais pas
mettre trop m'étendre je vais te laisser
peut-être évoquer le sujet de la
conditionnalité mais sur la
conditionnalités je veux pas doucher les
ardeurs de de notamment monsieur Petavy
qui a évoqué le sujet mais je veux quand
même rappeler que les conclusions de
notre rapport certes ne s'attache qu'à
un sujet de conditionnalité qui est la
négociation et en particulier les
négociations de branche est-ce que les
branches négocient des minimas qui soit
au dessus du SMIC c'est ça la question
qu'on s'est posée donc il y a évidemment
d'autres sujets de conditionnalités qui
peuvent être envisagées j'attire
simplement l'attention sur le fait que
plus on raffine les critères de
conditionnalités on introduisant des
objectifs sociaux des objectifs
environnementaux plus la complexité
intervient dans la mise en oeuvre d'un
dispositif de conditionnement et il faut
quand même faire attention à ça parce
que une des remarques et des critiques
qui étaient faites sur la
conditionnalité c'est justement cette
complexité et le risque d'usine à gaz
mais en tout cas sur les minima de
branches notre conclusion est quand même
assez clair c'est que aujourd'hui ça
n'est ni opportun ni souhaitable
je vais peut-être d'abord rebondir sur
ce dernier point
évidemment
je pense que le débat
mérite d'être creusé et je l'illustrerai
par ce que mon collègue Arthur de la
porte à a fait l'autre jour dans la
discussion générale sur sur le RSA au
moment on introduit des conditionnalités
sur le RSA il a pris un formulaire de
demande d'exonération des cotisations
sociales
ces deux pages une fois par an pour
l'entreprise
et dans le même temps on est capable
d'avoir quelque chose avec une
granularité très fine pour un
allocataire du RSA qui
tous les trimestres doit fournir ses
revenus et pour lesquels on va ajuster
le montant de son allocation en fonction
d'une situation très individualisée
composition du ménage etc et donc moi je
voudrais pas que l'argument de la
simplicité qui est un peu celui qui
avait présidé au cice pour dire les
choses voilà on fait simple on balance
et puis on voit on voit ce qui retombe
aujourd'hui à l'ère du Big Data des
données qui sont quand même parce que
les autres éléments de conditionnalité
ça peut être la situation financière des
entreprises alors c'est vrai que ça peut
être compliqué le niveau d'emploi la
qualité de l'emploi etc mais c'est des
sujets sur lesquels on est en capacité
aujourd'hui d'avoir des informations
quasiment en temps réel et donc je pense
qu'on peut
laisser ouvert mais ce sera l'objet du
débat du débat politique la manière
d'introduire c'est ces éléments
sur l'utilisation Caroline janvier en
plus ça fait écho à des échanges qu'on a
sur d'autres sur d'autres sujets
Marc il y a un an et dans son
avant-propos aujourd'hui dit
l'économie ainsi réalisée ça veut dire
par l'économie mais la recette liée
supplémentaire liée la suppression de
cet exonération bref le milliard et demi
Marc dit il faut le cibler sur ce qui
reste de cotisations patronales entre 1
et 1 sismique le reste plus beaucoup au
niveau du SMIC c'est on est passé de 42%
au début des années 90 à 6% aujourd'hui
niveau de de cotisation au niveau du au
niveau du SMIC donc voilà c'est
recentrer sur là où il y a une
présomption une efficacité une
efficacité avérée voilà je me suis je me
suis corrigé
moi je pense que dans le moment on peut
réaffecter ces ressources vers des
secteurs qui sont en besoin de
financement et c'est pour ça que l'année
dernière mon amendement c'était sur la
branche autonomie ça répond à un des
débats qu'on a régulièrement de savoir
quels sont les ressources qu'on peut
pour financer les EHPAD et les services
à domicile est-ce qu'on est capable
d'aller vers quelque chose ensemble moi
je vous le dis je préfère ré on a fait
une démarche transpartisane qui consiste
à dire on est pour supprimer moi je
préférerais l'échange qu'on puisse avoir
un amendement trans partisan juste pour
dire nous supprimons et on n'est pas
obligé de dire à quoi on affecte parce
que l'affectation c'est dans l'exposé
des motifs c'est de toute façon une
autre décision je veux dire juridico
financière ce n'est pas l'exposé des
motifs qui conditionne l'élément de la
suppression voilà donc dans un monde
idéal j'aimerais un amendement de la
commission des affaires sociales sur la
base ce rapport qui dit le rapport
propose la suppression du bandeau
famille
point voilà et et et et ceux qui veulent
allons-y voilà sinon on va se retrouver
dans la situation on va avoir un
amendement
Guedj un amendement ferrachi pour dire
le même objet avec des exposés des
motifs pour expliquer qu'on l'a pas fait
ensemble bon bref mais s'il y a des âmes
qui veulent se joindre à nous faisons-le
et je pense que ce serait aussi
on verra ce que dire à l'exécutif et que
ce que chacun des groupes sera amené par
loyauté fidélité à faire je pense que
c'est aussi de manière un consolider le
travail de la Mecque de notre commission
des affaires sociales et du Parlement en
général et donc ça pourrait être ça
pourrait être
utile je voudrais juste terminer sur un
point parce que ça a été évoqué quand
même
il y a un point de conscient alors si si
schématise
parce qu'il faut assumer c'est on se
lime la cervelle comme dit Montaigne
quand on est dans une mission de cette
de cette nature et on entend les
arguments de celui avec lequel on est
supposé ne pas être en pleine accord moi
j'assume que les éléments fournis me
permettent de dire que entre 1 et 1,6 mi
il y a une efficacité en termes d'emploi
au regard de l'objectif à signer
j'entends ce des détracteurs qui peuvent
dire oui mais on pourrait faire
autrement il y a un consensus très fort
plus qu'un consensus et d'ailleurs ça se
traduit par la proposition au-delà de
2,5 SMIC mais je voudrais pas qu'on se
ferme la porte sur les interrogations
qui ont été exprimées entre 1,6 et 2,5
ou là aussi je pense que que ce soit
pour les exonérations ça s'appelle le
bandeau maladie parce que c'est
essentiellement une cotisation
d'assurance maladie qui est exonéré pour
laquelle je pense qu'il y a il y a
approfondir le travail parce que là on
est
on est sur 20 à 25 milliards d'euros
voilà et je pense que ça pourrait être
l'étape d'après alors évidemment avec
des conséquences
l'argument que ce des organisations
patronales qui étaient assises à votre
place monsieur Viry mais ce n'est pas du
tout puisque les syndicats étaient aussi
et c'était à cette place quand on les a
auditionnés donc c'est pas une boutade
de ma part c'était de dire pour nous
c'est un élément pour corriger le
différentiel de coûts du travail avec
notamment nos voisins allemands sauf que
le rapport quand même dit que
l'essentiel des exonérations de
cotisations sociales ne profite pas
d'abord au secteur exposé à la
concurrence internationale qu'on a donc
là une contradiction de l'argument de la
compétitivité prix sur des secteurs qui
sont pas exposés à la concurrence
internationale je peux pas m'empêcher de
redire ici ce que je disais à l'époque
au moment de la création du cice ou
l'argument de l'emploi et de la
compétitivité ne collez pas sur dépend
entier qui n'étaient pas exposés à la
concurrence internationale dans
sale je prenais l'exemple à l'époque des
professions réglementées les
experts-comptables les avocats les
huissiers les notaires qui allaient
bénéficier du cice alors que par
définition ils sont pas dans un secteur
exposé la concurrence internationale et
que les allégements les baisses dièses
qu'ils allaient encaisser ne se
traduirait pas par de la création
d'emplois et mi bout à bout c'était un
milliard d'euros pour l'ensemble de ces
professions réglementées donc ça c'était
le côté voilà
et donc le le
rapport il est aussi utile en ce sens
qui documente la distribution à la fois
par secteur des exonérations de
cotisation sociale et où on voit et par
taille aussi les entreprises où on voit
que la cible est un peu ratée je vous
redonne qu'un seul chiffre les
exonérations des allègements Fillon ça
décroît c'est plutôt sain avec la taille
de l'entreprise
alors que pour le bandeau famille ça ne
décroît pas avec la taille de
l'entreprise on voit bien que il y a un
effet qu'on peut qualifier d'aubaine et
qui a rappelé
qu'à rappeler Marc qui se traduit moins
par un effet sur l'emploi que une
subvention au niveau de salaire
merci nous poursuivons donc avec les
questions des députés avec Madame
Valentin merci madame la Présidente vous
relancez donc le débat sur la politique
de réduction du coût du travail et vous
plaidez pour la suppression
d'exonération de cotisations sociales
sur les eaux salaires votre diagnostic
est assez partagé sans s'accorder sur
toutes les solutions à part celle de
supprimer le bandeau famille à l'heure
où l'exécutif se dit en quête d'économie
budgétaire la suppression de ce bandeau
famille rapporterait autour de 1
milliard 5 d'euros mais quel en sera
l'impact sur l'attractivité et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises à
l'heure où l'exécutif parle de
réindustrialisation de souveraineté
industrielle et agricole
vous vous êtes également penché sur
l'idée de conditionner les allègements
des
allègements et des objectifs comme la
revalorisation des salaires la création
d'emplois de qualité ou la fixation de
critères environnementaux nous voyons à
la lecture de votre apport que loin s'en
fout nous vous n'êtes pas toujours
d'accord concrètement que proposez-vous
pour améliorer la situation inquiétante
de l'emploi des seniors en France
sachant que le groupe LR avait proposé
des choses intéressantes lors du projet
de loi retraite votre apport soulève
malheureusement plus de questions qu'il
n'apporte de réponses toutes les
solutions proposées sont sujettes à un
débat et nous devons travailler ensemble
au sein de la commission sur ces sujets
votre apport est très minutieux il est
fondé
Monsieur Le Gac oui merci madame la
Présidente m'écouter je voudrais à mon
tour saluer le travail des deux
co-rapporteurs et puis saluer bien
évidemment l'esprit transpartisan qui
prévaut dans ce dans ce rapport on vient
de l'entendre encore alors
Jérôme j'ai répondu en partie à la
question que je voulais poser en fin de
son propos puisque bien évidemment il y
a
les entreprises qui sont exposées à la
compétition internationale parce que
même si le rapport est bien évidemment
très intéressant moi je suis resté juste
un petit peu ce matin parce que mais
c'était pas non plus l'objet de votre
rapport vous n'êtes pas rentré dans la
catégoriel dans le secteur par secteur
et pourtant il y a des différences bien
évidemment très importante d'un secteur
à l'autre moyen un sujet dont breton que
je suis particulièrement c'est le
secteur maritime
que que je défends c'est un secteur non
seulement les entreprises d'armement
peuvent demander une exonération des
cotisations patronales pour les marins
embarqués mais en plus on a mis en place
en du matin un head watch c'est à dire y
compris une exonération ou une aide
correspondant à la part salariale des
charges c'est pour dire que ce secteur
et et bien évidemment très très soutenu
et donc voilà il faut penser aux
entreprises qui sont exposées à la
globalisation à la mondialisation comme
le transport maritime par exemple merci
merci Monsieur Bazin merci madame la
Présidente messieurs les rapporteur je
vais apporter un peu de contradiction à
votre diagnostic car vous semblait avoir
fait l'impasse d'une réflexion sur la
compétitivité vous limitant à l'emploi
vous proposez de supprimer le bandeau
famille c'est-à-dire vous les supprimer
des exonérations de cotisations
familiale ce qui correspond à une
augmentation de prélèvement obligatoire
et donc une hausse des des charges à
plomb à chat en termes de compétitivité
malgré ces exonérations actuelles les
employeurs entre 2,5 et 3,5 SMIC ça
quitte de 6,4 milliards de cotisations
en plus par rapport à l'Allemagne car
notre système de protection sociale est
progressive plus le salaire élevé plus
le taux de cotisations sociales en
pourcentage de salaire brut est élevé
avec ce que vous proposez n'allez-vous
pas générer une perte de compétitivité
pour nos employeurs exposer à la
concurrence car il n'y a pas que les
experts-comptables et les notaires
deuxième question vous évoquez un gain
budgétaire d’un virgule 5 milliards pour
les caisses de l'État mais avec cette
augmentation de charge les recettes
dièses vont baisser n'avez-vous pas
surestimer le gain budgétaire troisième
question ensa de 2,5 SMIC il y aurait
7,8 points d'allègement au delà 0 points
n'allez-vous pas accentuer les effets de
seuil alors que ces exonérations de
charge ont pu inciter des employeurs à
augmenter les salaires n'allez-vous pas
désormais les dissuader autant de
questions qui me font douter du
bien-fondé de votre recommandation
merci Madame Gruet merci madame la
Présidente pour revenir sur les propos
de mon collègue Bazin le but premier de
ces nations et de favoriser
l'employabilité et ce qu'on n'aurait pas
du coup envie d'embaucher des salaires
avec une meilleure valorisation ce que
l'on perdrait s'ils sont moins exonérés
avec un événement vers le bas des
salaires des compétences et de la valeur
du travail monsieur Guedj la évoqué par
rapport à la refonte du financement du
secteur médico-social on a des
disparités territoriales fortes on
pourrait donc s'interroger sur le côté
gratuité de notre système de santé qui
se pose avec un reste à charge important
du financement de la dépendance vous
avez parlé de l'exonération des seniors
à l'emploi qui n'étaient pas pertinentes
avez-vous des pistes de réflexion à ce
sujet pour favoriser l'emploi des
seniors et enfin évitons de ne chercher
que des recettes supplémentaires mais
l'État et le gouvernement devrait
impérativement diminuer ses dépenses et
son train de vie comment ne peut le voir
avec la fiscalité sur les carburants
essayons plutôt de diminuer nos dépenses
plutôt que de chercher des recettes
supplémentaires
merci Monsieur dit Philippot merci
présidente et merci au rapporteur pour
leur pour leur travail en tout cas sur
le plan technique on voit
qu'effectivement les charges sur les
salaires à la fois salariale et
patronale globalement elles peuvent
aller 37 à 70 % dans la plupart des cas
on n'est pas loin des des 60 % et la
question qui se pose dans la société
d'aujourd'hui on a énormément de mal à
tomber en dessous des 7% de chômage et
où je parle pas du taux d'inactivité
avec en 11 ans 50% de bénéficiaires du
RSA en plus et bien le point cardinal
c'est la valeur du travail et quand un
salarié voit que entre le brut payé par
l'entreprise est-ce qu'il touche au
final en net il faut le diviser
quasiment par deux un peu moins mais
quasiment par deux et bien il y a de
quoi s'interroger et notamment sur le
financement de notre modèle social on
voit de plus en plus donc des ménages y
compris dans les classes moyennes qui
ont l'impression de toujours tout payer
de bénéficier d'aucune aide et le chèque
carburant dont a parlé le président et
encore une bonne exemple puisqu'il
bénéficiera des gens qui ont 14700 euros
de de de revenus fiscaux par an autant
dire pas grand mot notamment parmi les
gens qui travaillent et bien on a un
modèle généreux vous avez d'un côté les
gens qui payent toujours autant et les
voir tout et d'un autre côté ceux qui
bénéficient exclusivement des aides
c'est une fracture dans notre société en
terme de travail et donc la la le but
derrière la réflexion ne doit pas nous
conduire à alléger des charges que sur
des petits salaires on va enfermer des
gens tout près du SMIC pendant toute
leur carrière mais bien d'avoir une
réflexion bien plus large que ça sur
l'ensemble des salaires et sur la
revalorisation du travail et de tous les
travail notamment dans un contexte où la
pyramide des âges fait que pour la
génération qui arrive et bien il y a des
opportunités nombreuses comme jamais
pour peu que l'on veuille travailler
merci monsieur
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur je vous remercie pour ce
rapport et les aimants qu'il apporte
nous avons un niveau de prélèvement
obligatoire historiquement haut 45,4% du
SMIC et le rapport propose de monter
encore les cotisations sociales
concentrez les exonérations de
cotisations sur les salaires inférieurs
à 1,6 fois le SMIC c'est créer une
trappe à bas salaire plutôt que de
chercher à augmenter sans cesse le taux
de cotisations ou remettre en cause des
exonérations mieux vaudrait se
concentrer sur la base des cotisations
chômage emploi des seniors et emploi des
jeunes nous au rassemblement national
nous proposons une mesure depuis
longtemps favoriser et inciter les
entreprises à augmenter les salaires net
de 10%. comment en exonérant les
cotisations les hosts de 10% des
salaires inférieurs à trois fois le
montant du SMIC cette mesure peut
bénéficier à 90% des salariés notamment
au classe moyenne sans mettre en danger
les TPE et les PME par une hausse du
coût du travail alors messieurs à quand
une mesure aussi juste une
un gagnant-gagnant finalement pour nos
entreprises comme pour les salariés
merci Monsieur
c'est
bon madame la Présidente merci Monsieur
les rapporter merci pour votre travail
je note que les outre-mer ne sont pas
abordés est-ce que cela veut dire que
vos constats sont les mêmes dans nos
territoires est-ce que les allègements
de cotisation sociale ont eu un impact
différent ou spécifique sur l'ensemble
sur l'emploi et l'économie en outre-mer
par rapport à la France continentale si
oui pouvez-vous nous en dire plus par
ailleurs vous connaissez nos
spécificités avec des taux de chômage
recours et un tissus économiques fragile
est-ce que vous préconisations valent
aussi voir l'outre-mer en notre mère
nous avons un dispositif spécifique
appelé l'Odeum est-ce que cela est-ce
que vous avez pu étudier ce dispositif
est-il efficace et faut-il l'améliorer
enfin vous savez aussi que les salaires
sont plus bas chez nous dans le privé et
que dans le même temps il y a une
surmélioration qui est accordée aux
fonctionnaires par rapport à l'Hexagone
est-ce que cette spécifié a été pris en
compte dans vos travaux
merci Monsieur dare
merci madame la Présidente
je crois qu'il faut effectivement
poursuivre la recherche comme vous avez
indiqué que ça semblait nécessaire sur
cette question de trappe à bas salaire
parce que une réalité et que plus les
salaires sont bas plus on est exonéré et
donc je crois que ça contribue en
réalité à politique de modération
salariale et donc il faut poursuivre la
recherche pour ne pas opposer emplois et
qualité de l'emploi pour ne pas opposer
emploi et salaire et pour préserver la
part socialiser du salaire et il y a par
ailleurs besoin de politique de l'emploi
qui elle soit mieux cibler notamment sur
la taille des entreprises je constate
qu'il y a une possible majorité
peut-être qui est en train de se créer
pour revenir sur certaines exonérations
et moi l'amendement qui sera proposé je
n'en doute pas par nos deux Cora
porteurs je le signe et cet argent j'ai
pas de doute on trouvera à l'utiliser
merci Monsieur very
oui madame la présence moi je voulais
revenir sur la question de l'emploi des
seniors
on sait qu'actuellement on cherche la
martingale pour remettre en situation de
travail ou permettre le retour à
l'emploi de domaines de femmes de plus
de 50 ans et pour avoir écouté un grand
nombre d'acteurs de ce secteur
d'activité d'employeurs le coût du
travail des seniors et a priori a priori
un frein vous avez tous les deux exclus
l'idée d'un allègement de cotisation
spécifique pour ce public là j'aimerais
connaître ce qu'ils font de selon vous
cette voilà la position qui est la vôtre
moi j'avais peut-être à tort l'idée
qu'un coup allégé pour recruter un
seigneur pouvait être un facteur
incitant à l'emploi de ces femmes qui
sont hélas victimes de préjugés de
discrimination sur le marché du travail
merci monsieur
merci Madame présente oui je voulais
profiter de cette réflexion sur la sur
la légitimité actuelle des exonérations
qui existent
pour aborder la question de de la
valorisation du travail et répondre à
une hypothèse d'utilisation de de la
remise en cause de cette exonération si
elle si elle était mise en place et ça
n'a pas je crois été évoqué dans le
rapport en tout cas c'est une c'est une
proposition c'est à dire de transférer à
leur auprès l'exonération de ces
cotisations patronales sur une réduction
des cotisations salariales pour
augmenter de manière très concrète et
nette le revenu de tous les salariés
français avec une conséquence absolument
neutre pour les comptes publics ce
serait simple et concret je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Mathieu merci
madame la Présidente j'espère que la la
volonté la vérité je sais pas comment
dire de la proposition d'amendement
commune
[Musique]
merci Monsieur jarnigon oui merci madame
la Présidente je crois qu'il y a des
choses qui sont quand même difficiles à
entendre de la bouche de certains quand
on entend presque que les patrons sont
des gens qui se font de l'argent en
dormant je crois qu'il faut pas
confondre les sociétés du CAC 40 et les
4 millions de chefs d'entreprises qui
rame tous les jours et pour qui comment
dire les économies de charges sociales
permettent d'employer et surtout de
maintenir l'emploi alors bien sûr si on
supprime une masse importante
d'allègement je dis pas qu'il faut pas
en retoucher quelques-unes c'est
forcément du résultat en moins et ça
veut dire que cette vie est en moins et
je pense qu'il y a un rapprochement à
faire entre l'économie qui serait faite
sur les exonérations de charge et la
perte d'impôt sur les sociétés je crois
qu'il y a aussi la une réflexion sur la
prime d'activité ou la prime d'activité
a été mise en place pour je dirais
donner un plus à celui qui travaille par
rapport à celui qui travaille pas et
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas que la prime
d'activité soit intégrée dans les
salaires tout simplement augmenter les
salaires et supprimer la prime
d'activité il y a peut-être une
réflexion sur le sujet
merci
donc de nouvelles questions je redonne
la parole au rapporteur pour y répondre
merci merci à tous pour vos questions
alors là aussi je vais pas forcément
répondre point par point mais j'ai
groupé certaines thématiques qui sont
revenues dans plusieurs interventions et
notamment celle de Madame Valentin de
Monsieur Bazin de Monsieur viri sur deux
sujets sur la compétitivité l'emploi des
seniors
alors sur la compétitivité le rapport
s'y intéresse en tout cas il s'y
intéresse à hauteur des évaluations qui
existent sur
l'impact des exonérations et du cice
parce qu'il y a aussi des évaluations
qui ont porté sur le cice qui n'ont pas
mis en évidence de tels effets en
particulier sur la capacité exportatrice
des entreprises c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous permettons de dire
que les exonérations sur le salaire
n'ont pas forcément une inefficacité une
inefficacité avérée sur l'emploi mais
également sur la compétitivité
maintenant je suis tout à fait disposé à
dire que il faut continuer à creuser la
question j'attire simplement attention
sur le fait que des coûts les
comparaisons de coût du travail nominaux
entre la France et l'Allemagne entre la
France et d'autres pays donc assez peu
d'interprétations si on les rapporte pas
à la productivité respective des pays et
donc le bon indicateur ce sont les coûts
unitaires de production respectifs de
notre pays et par exemple de l'Allemagne
si vous voulez faire des comparaisons
avec l'Allemagne il se trouve que c'est
cool unitaire de production c'est ce que
montre notamment les rapports du groupe
d'experts sur le SMIC depuis un certain
nombre d'années ils ont eu tendance à
converger alors que nous étions en
retard en tout cas que nous avions des
coûts unitaires de production plus
élevés que l'Allemagne et c'est en
partie effectivement grâce aux
dispositif globaux d'exonération mais
pas forcément grâce aux dispositif
d'exonération sur les hausses salaires
sur le gain budgétaire que vous évoquez
qui pourrait baisser du fait d'une
baisse des recettes de l'IS là où je
suis un petit peu circonspect parce que
il faut je pense apporter la
démonstration que les recettes dièses
baisseraient
non on peut pas alors excuser
peut-être on s'expliquera hors de la non
pas on s'expliquera vous m'expliquerez
vous m'expliquerez
hors de la Commission et
sur et sur l'aspect et sur l'aspect et
sur l'aspect des seuils je pense et là
je vais peut-être aller un petit peu
plus dans votre sens je pense qu'on a
besoin d'avoir une réflexion globale
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs le point de
sortie de nos travaux qui vont se
prolonger dans le cadre de la Mecque sur
un profil différent des allègements qui
permettent d'éviter les seuils à 1,6 à
2,5 nous nous préconisons que le point
de sortie ne soit plus être,5 mais à 2,5
mais j'ai pu avoir l'occasion d'en
discuter avec certaines organisations
patronales je pense qu'il y a une
réflexion à voir sur la manière de
lisser sur l'intégralité du profil des
allègements et ça je pense que ce sont
des travaux qui nécessite les données
qui nécessite de l'expertise le
gouvernement souhaitera sans saisir ou
pas sur l'emploi des seniors
je redis parce que c'est important que
cette disposition consistant à exonérer
plus les cotisations sociales pour les
salariés serait
inefficace au sens où elle générerait du
gaspillage de l'argent public pour
certaines personnes ça générerait
probablement du maintien ou de la
création d'emplois mais pour beaucoup
d'autres ça générer des effets d'aubaine
pour la raison que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire que beaucoup de
salariés seniors ont une productivité
suffisamment importante pour ne pas
avoir leur emploi menacé quand bien même
en supprimera les exonérations quand
bien même on ne leur appliquerait pas
des exonérations plus importantes donc
ça c'est un élément important sur les
pistes alors sur les pistes alternatives
on va pas refaire la discussion qu'on a
eu pendant le débat sur les retraites
sur l'index seniors moi pour ma part je
considérais que c'était une piste
intéressante j'attire votre attention
sur le fait que les partenaires sociaux
vont avoir à nég fichiers sur ce sujet
là que un document d'orientation va
alors être envoyé incessamment par par
le gouvernement pour opérer une
négociation interprofessionnelle je
pense qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'enjeux qui sont sur la table et
notamment le fait de compenser les
personnes qui sont au chômage au-delà
d'un certain âge et qui peuvent être
réticents à reprendre des emplois parce
que
on subit parfois quand on est senior une
forme de déco de salariale liée au fait
que on arrive au chômage avec des
niveaux de salaire un peu plus
importants que les autres salariés après
avoir progressé à l'ancienneté tout au
long de sa carrière et que il peut être
utile de compenser les personnes qui
sont dans cette situation là pour les
inciter à reprendre un emploi ça fait
partie des pistes qui sont sur la table
notamment en cas de la négociation
assurance chômage pour les partenaires
sociaux j'espère qu'ils iront dans cette
direction là ils ont terminé avec un
autre élément qui a fait l'objet
d'annonce et auquel je suis moi-même
très attaché c'est de généraliser pour
changer la culture des entreprises
vis-à-vis des salariés seniors des
dispositifs de testing le ministre
Olivier du soft a annoncé que un testing
sur l'accès à l'embauche des seniors
serait lancé dans les prochains dans les
prochaines semaines et j'en profite pour
faire un peu la promotion d'une
proposition de loi que j'ai déposée pour
généraliser ces dispositifs de testing
donc je pense que ils peuvent aboutir
des changements de comportement voilà
peut-être juste un point de de rebond
sur
sur sur le sur le point de Monsieur
marquiau et cette proposition que vous
avez défendue lors de la précédente
niche du rassemblement national alors je
vais pas refaire toute l'eau des
échanges qu'on a pu avoir à l'occasion
de cette proposition j'avais beaucoup
d'arguments pour dire que ça n'était pas
une bonne proposition pour des raisons
de principes pour des raisons
d'opérationnalités pour des raisons de
complexité je m'en tiendrai simple
constat qui est que votre propre
rapporteur a déposer à l'occasion de
cette proposition de loi une demande de
rapport au gouvernement pour en étudier
la faisabilité ce qui est quand même
relativement inédit s'agissant d'une
proposition de niche donc ça je pense
révèle les failles et les limites de
cette proposition et je n'irai pas plus
loin dans le détail et enfin s'agissant
de l'amendement commun rien c'est
quelque chose c'est quelque chose qui
est sorti de la bouche de mon collègue
young Edge je redis qu'il me semble
qu'il me semble que les conséquences
politiques que nous tirons l'un et
l'autre de la suppression du bandeau
famille et bien non pas véritablement
n'ouvre pas beaucoup de possibilités
mais continuons en discuter je suis
toujours ouvert à la discussion
poursuivre oui peut-être une réponse à
Monsieur aussi sur le sujet
outre-mer parce que comme on vous l'a
dit on n'avait pas le temps de se de se
pencher sur les dispositifs spécifiques
il y a des niches sociales qui portent
sur l'outre-mer dont on peut interroger
l'efficacité bien sûr les éléments
généraux s'appliquent en outre-mer
nous n'avons pas terminé avec nos
travail d'évaluation puisque c'est un
travail au long cours et on aura
peut-être l'occasion effectivement de se
pencher sur des niches géographiques ou
sectorielles
oui rapidement parce que vraiment les
éléments ont été évoqués sur ce dernier
point la question de la suite du rapport
sera posé je le dis avec
avec Cyril et zacibile à nos côtés
aujourd'hui dans le programme de travail
de la Mecque on aura à
se poser la question de
la poursuite de ce travail d'évaluation
en articulation avec ce qui va venir
dans la dans le dans la laque au mois de
mai au mois de mai prochain et comme
Marc Lady à l'instant on n'a pas
aborder les exonérations ciblées qui
peuvent être territoriales
dans les zones dans les quartiers
politiques de la ville dans les zones de
robinet revitalisation rurale ou pour
certaines catégories de population
des apprentis des jeunes etc
donc on aura on aura prolongé ce travail
sur sur l'amendement je vais je vais
livrer un scoop je serai obligé de voter
même si je suis pas d'accord avec
l'exposé des motifs l'amendement de
marque Ferracci est-ce que est-ce que la
réciproque sera vraie
donc plus simple faisant le faisant le
ensemble mais moi je le dis tout de
suite je proposerai à l'ensemble des
membres de la commission un amendement
dès l'instant où ce rapport aura été
autorisé à sa publication pour aller
pour aller en son sens et il y a un
dernier point que je n'aurais pas qu'on
enjambe quand même je l'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure mais au moment où le
PLFSS on vient de le recevoir tous sur
nos boîtes et qui a le sujet de de des
ressources je pense je crois que c'est
Arthur de la porte qu'il évoquait tout à
l'heure dans son intervention
que la question de la non compensation
et des raisons objectiver de la non
compensation de 2019 de la
désocialisation des heures
supplémentaires j'ai compliqué
aujourd'hui de continuer à
la légitimée et avoir cette anomalie
dans le tableau justement l'annexe 5 de
la du palais FSS je vais voir le
document j'ai pas encore eu le temps de
le compulser il vient de nous arriver
d'un conseil des ministres ce matin
mais de voir de voir cette exonération
non compensée je pense que ça vaudra le
coup de reposer la question et d'aller
en ce sens lors des débats voilà et à
mon tour terminé par ce par quoi a
commencé Marc vraiment remercier
les administrateurs de de la commission
des affaires sociales parce que comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer ça a été avec
beaucoup d'agilité et de et de souplesse
très précieux pour la rédaction du
rapport comme d'ailleurs la parfaite
collaboration de l'ensemble des
administrations je pense à la direction
générale du travail à la DGE à la DSA à
la DSS qui ont contribué à éclairer nos
travaux voilà
beaucoup messieurs les rapporteurs pour
la qualité de vos travaux et la qualité
de ces échanges je pense que ces
échanges ont permis de montrer d'abord
l'intérêt que suscite le sujet pour les
députés qui ont un cœur aussi d'évaluer
nos politiques publiques qu'il
subsistent encore de nombreuses
questions sur la conditionnalité sur
l'impact que pourrait avoir de nouvelles
exonérations pour cibler par exemple
l'emploi des seniors
j'ajouterai quand même peut-être un
point de vigilance aussi sur l'impact
que pourrait avoir un retour en arrière
et la sensibilité que nos chefs
d'entreprise peuvent avoir à des signaux
de d'éventuelles nouvelles hausses
puisque c'est comme ça que ça qu'on
arriverait
dans le cas de suppression d'exonération
de cotisations sociales et qui me semble
important que dans les travaux qui
doivent continuer à être menés je pense
que c'est ce que l'ensemble des députés
Apple puisse être bien pris en compte
l'impact d'un éventuel retour en arrière
dans l'engagement de nos chefs
d'entreprise et en question de de
confiance dans le marché dans leur
marché et dans le dans les perspectives
d'emploi qu'ils pourraient engager mais
aussi de rémunération de leur salarié
dans un contexte éventuel hausse de ma
salariale et de également d'inflation
donc nous avons encore je crois pour la
commission de nombreux travaux sur ce
champ il nous est posé aujourd'hui la
question de
l'accord de la Commission pour la
publication de ce rapport je pense que
personne ne voit ici d'objections à ce
que ce rapport puisse être publié
si des merci beaucoup
notre prochaine réunion sera consacrée à
l'examen en application l'article 91 du
règlement des amendements en tritres 3
et 4 du projet de loi pour le plein
emploi 3 à 5 pardon oui on a un
cinquième titre pour le projet plein
emploi la date et l'heure vous seront
précisés dans une prochaine convocation
merci bonne journée à tous à tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle